let's speak to this uh transport
secretary grant shaps here on behalf of
the government this morning good morning
thank you for finding us
it's good to have you in the studio uh
let's deal with the data to start with
um as far as the omicron variant is
concerned how many people in hospital
this morning with omicron the last week
last figure we had unchanged the 10
people in hospital we know there's been
a single death
and we know there's probably around 9
000 people who have tested positive at
this stage how many on ventilators uh
non-ventilators that i'm aware of
although i don't specifically know the
condition of the tendon hospital so
there may be some of those person that
died did they die
uh having gone into hospital with
omicron or did they again i don't know
the specific details of that individuals
so does that suggest we've got this
under control
no i mean what we do know is that it's
doubling every two to three days which
is incredibly fast and the thing about
doubling rates like that is you can go
from seemingly almost nothing of course
to suddenly uh it becoming a thing which
overwhelms you and i think that the
hospitalizations are in many senses a
lagging part of this because we know
from
coronavirus as a whole it takes a while
two or three weeks before people find
themselves in hospital and sadly another
two or three weeks before people
die although of course we hope it might
be
more
less
less severe we just don't know whether
it is at this stage well dr angelique
cutsia
as you know south african scientist
saying the uk is being alarmist
in its response well i'm surprised to
hear that and actually i know there are
different voices in south africa and
i've listened to a lot of them if you
look at south african hospitalizations
you see that very very quick as i say
the doubling rate becomes an issue and i
was having a look at the data on this
just yesterday morning
and you can see the speed at which
people are going into hospital now there
are all sorts of arguments about how
severe it is how long you spend in
hospital
the big problem that we want to try and
avoid is having our hospitals so full up
that when it comes to you needing to
call uh you know for for an ambulance
accidents emergency elective surgery
that you can't get into hospital to do
any of those things and it's our
responsibility obviously as a government
as a country to make sure that that
doesn't happen yeah although there are
only nine in hospital aren't there sadly
one person but it's this whole thing's
only a couple weeks old at this point
we've known about it since october well
in terms of the number of people having
it here we know that you know the first
case was in october of course but if i
look in the last three months ago sure
but if i look in the last two days for
example
i can see there's three or four thousand
new cases
right at the beginning of this and let's
call that the beginning of december
when we when we first started to pick
them up um here
the cases were increasing at just two or
three a day so you see what happens the
doubling rate means that if you don't
act you'd be the first person on your
program to say why didn't you act sooner
do you recognize the figure of 200 000 a
day contracting covered 200 000 a day is
based on the fact that people get tested
and when they're tested they're included
in the official cases but the office of
national statistics and others have
always made estimates of what the likely
total
amount of coronavirus is and that
includes people who haven't necessarily
received a positive test as yet a
cambridge statistician professor spiegel
holzer says that's just naughty without
context oh well again i'd say i think it
does need to be used in context and and
very clear about it there's a difference
if you take a test and that test is
positive then that gets included in the
data but there are other organizations
including the office for national
statistics as coincidentally my family
has been on the office of national
statistics monthly survey right since
the beginning of
coronavirus was randomly
selected i suppose
and they do those wider surveys now they
they they do those tests monthly on the
whole population to take a sample size
uh so people are so you've got a regular
baseline for these things okay and
that's how these you know estimates of
what it might mean in the wider
population abroad come about through
those significant sample sizes more
figures um reported in the newspapers
this morning more than a million people
could be in isolation by christmas day
is that a figure that you recognize well
look i hope it's the case that all these
steps we're taking
most significant of all getting people
boosted means that we don't end up in
that kind of situation um the the
frightening thing is if you do nothing
if it doesn't turn out to be less severe
than we think uh we hope uh if uh if if
we just left it to chance as i've
already said you you'll be having me
interesting you don't recognize us
because well we hope to avoid anything
like that of course yeah in the in the
meantime um the last three days i've
gone on to the nhs website to look for
the lateral flow tests that they're not
there
that's a supply issue um should we be
prioritizing care home residents and nhs
workers so that
nhs workers can go to work and care home
residents can have business first of all
just on the um tests themselves these
lateral flow tests which actually
uniquely and as far as i can see there
aren't other countries who've been
supplying these free of charge to their
citizens and major economies don't
haven't generally been doing this and we
have in this country you're right that
particularly since the
new measures the booster program asking
people to be tested come in
it can be difficult at different times a
day to get those i did notice yesterday
actually that at certain time today you
could get them they're coming back in
there's plenty of supply in the country
what we're having issues with is the
distribution route and i know my
colleagues at the health department are
working with royal mail with amazon with
others to try and make sure that
distribution gets understood you can
still
they also say potentially not should you
uh be prioritizing care home residents
absolutely i think you know care homes
hospitals very very important and most
important of all if there's one single
message from all of this boosters 24
million people boosted already i saw
huge queues just i walked past huge
queues yesterday of people responding to
what the prime minister said on sunday
night and going in booking and waiting
for many walk-ins can't say the brits
are not doing their bit that's they
are queuing up for hours and hours um
the scots are saying the public uh
should be limited socializing to three
households at a time in the run-up to
christmas good idea
well look every part of the uk will have
a look at this and then they make their
own plans the scots i think have issued
as guidance rather than law in their
particular case we set out in england
for people watching this in england what
we
want to do parliament's now uh voted on
it um and uh right now that does not
include limitations we want people to be
able to enjoy christmas this year we're
certainly in a better position than we
were this time last year so the scots
can do that but the br the english are
not doing it yeah it's only in guidance
yeah in scotland but that's but that's
right we we want people to be sensible
but to enjoy their christmas to get
tested and we have two things this year
which we didn't last year one's tests
and two
jabs and and now even booster jabs
that's all happened in the last year so
we're in a much better position
okay everybody i talked to minister um
says to me when you get that minister on
your show can you get them to guarantee
there will not be any further
restrictions ahead of christmas well
look i i dominic rob yesterday said
there won't be as long as it's this
variant well well look i i i know that
we've taken a huge number of steps we've
already got over 40 people boosted uh
people watching this can help by making
sure they book their booster jab if it's
been three months since their second one
and that way we can all enjoy christmas
and so i think with um some confidence
we can say that people are going to be
able to enjoy their christmas get
together with their friends and family
uh and no more restrictions
and with only what has already been okay
will everybody be jabs by new year's eve
um everyone would have been offered a
jab who wants one are you sure that's
the plan uh it depends somewhat on your
on your viewers of course people have to
actually come forward we can't make
people and do that everyone wants you
once we've had one but
offered a jab i imagine that some people
for various different reasons uh may uh
get their jabs in the new year where for
example they're having to wait because
it's more than three months of whatever
reason they less than three months and
they didn't have their second jab until
whenever so obviously some people will
still be coming through the system the
key thing is everyone to be offered a
jab and as we're seeing you know again
there's no other country i'm aware of
certainly no other major economy where
over 40 of their citizens have already
had the booster jab we got the original
vaccine program done first and we're
getting this booster program done first
and that will give us better protection
including against omicron and when will
the third job be an absolute essential
to get into places um that that we
agreed to the parliament agreed to
yesterday so so it will not be the
gatherings in the lineup not this year
um
i think we'll have to see what the
evidence shows us nearer the time i
think i mean i think your question's
hinting at will there be a time at which
three jabs is then saying that you're
fully vaccinated
it wasn't very soft
no you're right you're right
and and look i speak to my opposite
numbers in other countries transport
secretaries from around the world
particularly from the g7 this year that
which we're
we're hosting and uh they're saying look
we're going to switch to requiring
people to have that third jab before
they're able to come into their
countries so i think and eventually it
becomes inevitable because other
countries will require it for us you
just don't know when yes and i i don't
know what that time will be not this
year as i say but right now potentially
okay
let's talk about this um tory rebellion
dominic rabb told me yesterday deputy
prime minister sat just there he said
he'd be surprised if the number was as
high as 70. it was almost a hundred
you've lost the dressing room
well i'd look i'd say nobody wants to
curtail people's freedoms and mps
rightly take that very very seriously
and have to think about how they uh how
they how they vote in the end parliament
uh passed these measures with the
majority of nearly 250 but each
individual mp has had to think it
through very carefully um and i i
completely understand that we don't want
to have to put these steps in place on
the other hand as i said a couple of
times we don't want to afterwards end up
having to look back and wish we had it's
not answering my question
how so and you've lost the dressing room
even a apology even an mp that is the
newest mp that happens to be a
conservative um mp uh and even he voted
against the prime minister well as i say
losing the dressing room would be
parliament not supporting you parliament
has supported these measures um and i
but i had to rely on labor though well
if labour hadn't voted they still would
have gone through of course but uh you
know based on on the numbers but that's
not the point and i do appreciate that
every mp has to think very carefully and
and look particularly as a conservative
i hate the idea of curtailing people's
freedom to act and to do different
things as it so happens we've actually
managed because of our
vaccine program and booster program to
be one of the most open of certainly
european countries in most other places
including for example
in france you have to show vaccine
certification just to get on a train
long distance
but we've not had to bring those things
in here yeah because of the booster
program and i think it's really
important that we keep reminding all of
our you know all of us that the way to
prevent having to do these things is to
make sure we all get our jabs and
boosters what have you lose the
by-election will you have lost the
dressing room then well look
governing's you know difficult uh and
you don't have uh you know there's
especially with something like corona
virus there's no text but there's no
manual to work through and i think you
know this government will have done some
things where we we haven't got it right
and looking back through coronavirus
we've also done some things where we've
absolutely got it spot on what have you
done and as say things like the vaccine
program has been one of those
in mid parliament all sorts of different
things happen so you will wait shaping
up to potentially accept that you might
lose
having these conversations
so it was absolutely absolutely not
going to happen the bookies have said
you've got no chance it's the lib dems
well i i i one thing i've known from for
being in politics for for a while and
haven't been party chairman is never to
become the pundit on your on your sofa
you've got plenty of guests who'll do
that why don't we leave it to the voters
but you're preparing for potentially
losing i said i don't want to preempt
what voters decide to do that's their
business and i'm sure afterwards you can
analyze the results or i'm sure there
are plenty of people to do that for you
what i do know is that people in north
shropshire have the opportunity and i
met the candidate um to vote for for a
potential mp who worked very very hard
for the for their area and i know about
all of his transport priorities because
i've been up to see them okay let me ask
you another couple questions before i
let you go these downing street parties
um they just won't go away will they
sean bailey's reside from his role as
chair of the london assembly police and
crime committee um after that picture
did he do the right thing
well absolutely right thing to resign
but the wrong thing to have held a party
i mean point out this is not a uh this
this is something that was organized by
uh that i guess
is who you're a campaign and team yeah i
see in that picture apparently four
uh conservative party workers who are on
secondment where disciplinary action has
already been taken
and you know to answer your question
it's disgraceful to have a party like
that break the rules that's unacceptable
and the consequences that follow
following so if he stepped down what
about the prime minister he was
ringmaster over a quiz with names like
professor quiz witty hans face first
place next slide please and the
participants were told to go out by the
back door once it was over well come on
i i saw the i mean the photo you just
showed um shows a lot of people not
socially distanced absolutely
unacceptable disgraceful i saw the photo
of the prime minister so so-called uh
quiz
saturn
that was him but who was he on the zoo
and he was reading out the names of the
quiz uh of the teams
face first place come on prime minister
hold on a minute he sat in front of a
computer thanking his staff for 10 or 15
minutes for having worked through
christmas on a virtual you did a ride
you did a quiz ride i don't think
there's really an issue as far as i'm
aware there's no issue that i'm familiar
with where you can't have quiz names
over the video screen at christmas i
think that's all getting a little bit
silly the other picture you just showed
well that is obviously okay there's lots
more to ask about that but i do we're
over so i just want to ask you briefly
before i let you go as a parent
how can you um reconcile the abuse that
children
are facing as a result some would say um
of lockdown those two babies the images
that we've seen
i i don't i can't even i i actually um
you know i said to my to my wife you
know as as as a dad i said to my wife i
actually can't read the detail i had to
force myself on that first picture it's
heartbreaking actually heartbreaking to
see it and um you know lockdown or no
lockdown obviously there's no excuse i
know that my colleague nadim zahawi
the education secretary's um looking
into this and announcing the inquiries
are not enough now i know there is
nothing that will bring that back and it
is you know difficult to see it in any
other way as just just pure evil yeah
and this was the little boy last week as
well
heartbreaking absolutely heartbreaking
every parent in the country will be
reading this and seeing the story this
morning and feeling the same way
i must let you go it's great to have you
in the studio finally come back soon
thank you very much thanks